radical and repugnant congresswoman
lauren bobert is now openly trying to
destroy the constitution the very
constitution that she claims to love
that she claims to
treat almost as if it were a sacred text
or a religious doctrine of sorts she now
wants pastors to preach
how churches can influence the direction
of government now understand that
in order to be
non-profit entities and not pay all
sorts of different taxes
churches actually have to avoid politics
altogether and what lauren bobert is
suggesting is not just that churches
get involved in politics but that
churches actually get directly involved
in trying to influence government rather
than just their parishioners or the
people uh attending their church
services and this is the second time in
three weeks that lauren bobert is openly
hostile to separation of church and
state enshrined by the constitution and
bill of rights and they will often not
even justify it in any real way
occasionally they will say you know the
founding fathers were christian so
therefore we don't need separation of
church and state well they may have been
some of them anyway uh but they
recognized the importance of that being
their personal
set of beliefs and not part of
civil government so let's get into the
first clip here lauren beauberg says we
we need churches influencing government
sorry lauren that's not what the
constitution says
and i believe that great patriots all
throughout this nation and christians
will begin to position
themselves
in these days and these times that
pastors would have a boldness to speak
from the pulpit of their churches to
direct and inform the church on how to
influence the direction of government
[Applause]
that is the opposite of what the
constitution says needs to be the way
the country is organized and in fact
we already have i mean this the sad
reality is
much like the checks and balances that
trump ignored and seems to have
successfully ignored at least for now in
terms of consequences
in theory
when churches do politics they lose
their tax-exempt status
in practice i've been covering for close
to two decades churches that do politics
and we almost never see them lose their
tax-exempt status so
both what lauren bobert is saying is
both
completely against
both the constitution and the tax code
and they'll probably get away with it
because there is very limited
willingness or resources among the irs
to actually police this now this is not
a new thing with lauren bober this is
lauren bobert's new calling she recently
again in the trend of trashing the very
constitution that she claims to revere
she said she's tired of separation of
church and state she called it junk in
fact the reason we had so many over
reaching regulations in our nation is
because the church
complied
the church is supposed to direct the
government the government is not
supposed to direct the church that is
not how our founding fathers intended it
and i'm tired of this separation of
church and state junk that's not in the
constitution it was in a stinking letter
and it means nothing like what they say
it does
so that is open hostility open hostility
to what is actually in the constitution
now of course the establishment clause
is where we see
that enshrined congress shall make no
law respecting an establishment of
religion
that also means putting the
non-religious at any kind of
disadvantage it's one way or the other
and
the
founding fathers
seemed better
not that they were perfect at separating
their personal beliefs
from what should be
the role of religion in government
um when they talk about you know they
they it is true when they when she
refers to a letter she's talking about
thomas jefferson thomas jefferson
is maybe responsible for the most famous
use of the metaphor separation of church
and state from a letter where he talks
about a wall of separation
and the new thing that republicans love
to do is to say
it's not really in the constitution
it was just in a letter that jefferson
wrote
but
first of all
the letters are relevant in telling us
the intent of the founding fathers you
know james madison
also in in
private what we call private
communications made clear that any
uh government involvement in religion or
support for any particular religion or
even the placing in a preferred status
of religion over non-religion would be
improper and inappropriate for
government
and also you have the establishment
clause so
as often is the case oh democrats are
going to
try to steal the election and use fraud
and all this actually they did it they
are that they are actually the ones that
that did that thing
uh whenever they point to something we
should be wondering are they actually
the ones doing it and when they say the
left is destroying the constitution and
wants to use it as toilet paper or
whatever the case may be
we should be wondering whether whether
it is actually they
who are trying to do that and that is
exactly what lauren bobert is trying to
do now to their credit
there are some
more mainstream republicans
mitt romney for example
who
doesn't agree with this perspective he
is
as as far as i have most recently seen
from mitt romney he is personally very
religious he's mormon and on and on but
he would take issue with what lauren
bobert says in this clip
many other republicans won't support it
publicly but they like what she's saying
so they'll just shut their mouths
and then you have the ones that are just
full floated full-throated endorsers
of what lauren bobert is saying and it's
dangerous
and uh if they end up getting more power
whether it's the house senate more
governorships at the state level they
will try to make this establishment of
christianity in government even more of
a reality than it already is because to
some degree it already is there
uh
which religion gets federal holidays
just christianity right i mean eastern
christmas
there's no other religion that gets
federal holidays um and so many other
things that we've talked about ten
commandments displays at courthouses and
on and on and on it will get worse